hello and welcome to this video this is
the first one of a couple of CEO nce
videos that I'm going to release in the
next couple of weeks I haven't done
those for a long while but I have played
a couple of games and recent monthly I
think it's maybe almost a year that has
since then I did such a video I played a
couple of interesting games and I'm
going to present them on ganser in the
next couple of weeks I also be on
vacation a bit so not quite sure when
exactly but let's let's kick off with
this video I'm going to start with the
most interesting game who had that I
played in the last year and also the
most attractive to watch maybe um yeah
let's let's get going this is a game
played in January this year um late
January um it was played in the second
German leak the slider Bundesliga
secondly on board one between my club
Dean's Larkin and carton back sm carton
back and yeah we actually we am finished
in next to last or last place how we may
counted and counted in the sleek so it
wasn't a very successful a year for the
club I had a pretty good result and one
reason for this was this game my
opponent is an exam de cough Sean he's a
grandmaster from the Ukraine and at the
time of playing he was rated 2596 so
very close to the 2600 mark yeah let's
have a look at this game I played 90 of
three and he went G sixes already came
as a surprise um I mean I wasn't quite
sure if i'm going to play him because my
opponents team had a couple of people
that potentially could play on board one
so i did make a preparation but it
wasn't very very conclusive because if
you have to prepare for three people who
also have a wide opening repertoires it
quickly comes to the point where it's
it's it's pointless so I knew his
repertoire roughly bottom
it was a surprise he was normally
playing the Greenfeld and all right
let's say he was playing like lines like
this but it's possible that he found in
his preparation games of mine and where
I mean this is a non-starter if you want
to win a game with black white has this
line which is super solid awesome
Queenie for related lines where black
can you hardly win the game if Y
displaying it well and at least my my
opinion if I was especially solid so my
take is he wanted to avoid this kind of
anti green cards and yeah I get out of
normal theory quickly g6 not a move
ahead on the radar at all ok I played
deformed as I usually do against g6 I'm
pretty much shutting down any green felt
type of things Bishop g7 and deform yeah
now here's a parting of the ways black
can do many things he can go with D 64
Kings Indian kind of style um here I
usually go either c4 or C 3 depending on
my mood on that day she falls or very
likely was pulled into a king's indian
here he however played something
entirely different he played the move d5
and yet as means that i was out of book
on on new three I had never seen this
this idea however I'm looking at this
after the game i actually discovered
that he had played this once before and
in one single game so um yeah it's
something that i could have seen before
that he plays it but well it's just one
game out of 100 son um yeah okay why
takes it of course and after greene
takes we have a scandinavian type of
position and not something that i have
on the board every day so this is a an
interesting choice to get the white
player maybe a little bit out of his
comfort zone and even though it's a very
classical normal kind of position that
every player should play somehow it felt
a little bit unusual
Dravid on the board yeah okay you went
back to the eighth and yeah here i was
thinking briefly um I didn't want to
spend lots of time on such a position
and they played age 3 which is maybe not
the most yeah it is straight forward
move I felt that Bishop g4 could be
annoying to ya put pressure on my night
and thus attack deform this is why I
went age three I wanted to prevent
Bishop g4 it's not strictly necessary I
mean I found games where strong players
played Knight c3 of course as a sideline
but would still there were games where
this was some where this was played um
it's possible I mean Bishop g4 is not
the end of the world what can still do
this and maybe after night since six
play d5 if this kind of quick attack on
d4 is happening in the first place so h3
not really necessary but it's not a bad
move either and he went night h6 again
not something that I had anticipated
that much but it makes a quite some
sense the night is aiming for the f5
Square to put pressure on my default
pawn and here I took a little bit of
time and tried to figure out if I can do
something very concrete against this I
thought about g4 here a bit um this is
not a particularly bad move ultimately
but it's still something that did not
convince me that much the idea is that
for example after castles why can try
something like Bishop here and try Queen
d2 which would trap the night actually
it has no squares the problem is that
black always has this quick f5 move and
this sir is attacking g4 and putting
lots of pressure there and if I have to
go g5 and he goes back here this black
set up all of a sudden makes lots of
sense yeah he's going to be five coming
yeah g-form it's not a brilliant idea
you can also go f5 immediately here
there are some funky ideas for example
after Knight c3 this i calculated a bit
like he has all of sunday night is
attacked and yeah I mean something like
this is kind of interesting for white I
mean there are some files here G and H
file but again it was a bit too wild for
my taste and it didn't it didn't doesn't
really convince objectively and so I was
just went Bishop e2 of course Knight c3
is also possible he went nine f5
attacking deformed i had to advance it
yeah i think black can be happy probably
with this opening position um he got
this kind of unconventional type of
setup that he wanted and his object
objectively in any trouble I'm c6 and
black took their giving me an isolated d
porn yeah the important thing is to
understand that this is a big difference
if the deep on the isolated d point is
on d4 on d5 on d5 it usually um yeah is
an active asset that white has or the
iqp side has because it limits black's
pieces a little bit for example it nails
down the e6 porneia and it can help to
get to control important squares for
example on any be six then c6 gets to be
a square that white might be able to use
I was kind of I was okay with my
position I think it looks like I can
develop easily and nothing yeah nothing
special is happening um yeah here White
has a couple of a couple of options
rookie one Bishop f4 yeah normal
development moves however I i figured
that queen bee three is an interesting
choice um clearing the D 1 square
quickly for look and have helped that
sometimes if he goes night to see five
the queen is not badly placed on a three
I saw that he now can win upon but I
simply couldn't believe that black is
able to afford to do that and
interestingly enough he decided to grab
that pole
zone yeah we would see what happens and
I think probably what black should do
here is a move like Knight to f6 just a
normal move to get the pieces
coordinated yeah Bishop f4 Brooke 81
look everyone this is between I think
equal and I think I like why they're
always like space but it's not a big
deal that the engines give white a
slight advantage of this position but
nothing special um yeah he bent 95 okay
Queen a 3 not much choice there yeah and
now okay here is also um still a
possibility for him to not grab the pawn
what he did is he took on c3 and yeah
essentially grabbed a pawn and I'm not
quite sure what his rationale was maybe
he thought that I wouldn't give the pawn
and take on c5 which is a very weak move
in a way I'm yeah black it was back and
it's totally okay anyway let's not get
ahead of ourselves what he still can't
do is is to play b6 and cover this night
um I think again I like why do I always
like the space connected with this pawn
but black here is probably kind of okay
now like Queen here develop things maybe
we should be seven I know it's it looks
kind of okay still for black hair I mean
again I like white but it's nothing that
is any media trouble the computer says
like 0.2 or something and nothing
nothing special yeah but let's go to
that situation he took on c3 and this is
some a very risky move and probably
objectively also not great um I'm not
sure what again what his idea was um
maybe he misjudged the position after
grabbing the porn or he thought that
maybe judging for my games that would be
too conservative to give the pawn I
don't know but it's just this is just a
terribly weak
dia to play this and yeah just trade
stuff from he black will get b6 with the
tempo and is totally fine and after
Queen takes yeah white has grabbed this
important of here in Cairo bishop and he
would always have enough compensation
for the pawn I mean even though here we
are already talking about some concrete
problems that black will face but even
on general terms this is a fantastic
compensation he took the pawn of course
um and then it is some I mean I would
absolutely both black I would never take
that partners must say would be
absolutely too scared it is also
possible that he was just were thinking
okay I want to win this game which is
pretty clear what you that this was in
his intention yeah with the whole
opening choice and maybe he said okay
I'm going to just out calculate you now
in this complications it's possible I
mean it's it's risky but it's an
approach that that you can you can take
i think it's it's too much risk but
we'll see what happens and the next
phase of the game the next couple of
moves and you can question both sides
choices because it is very very
difficult to play this right now mostly
has two moves and I considered consider
the two moves and maybe came to wrong
conclusions the moves that come into
consideration your most are Bishop c4
which is what I played or rook t1 and
rook t1 also looks very logical
attacking the Queen and the Queen has to
somehow deal with the fact that this
night is hanging and if he goes back I
like to see six um I'm getting very a
good play with things like that yeah I'm
threatening made on g7 and yeah I'm
already winning material here he has to
move the Queen to e6 autos to e form and
the move that worried me during the game
remember correctly I think this was the
move was Queen to before I couldn't
quite figure out um what happens here
and move that it's now quite strong that
I did not evaluate correctly either was
rookie one I move that I didn't have on
the radar I felt it probably a little
bit unnatural to move it again but it is
strong it threatens the discovered
attacks on the Queen and also they're
still g4 and Bishop age six and black
black has some trouble here there the
engine ultimately and it gives queen to
c6 yeah it's difficult to not play this
if you look at stuff like that now you
see how quickly black gets into trouble
here and maybe before well where's the
night going to go and we like here so
now we have discovered it looks like
this this and like it's going to get
kilt yet so it's not not playable this
position and rookie one was very very um
yeah they're very promising I think yeah
this a rock d 1 and then he look even
this is strongest relatively speaking
but still after g4 night back Bishop age
6 i'm going to win some material and
rocky one was stronger I didn't see um
Queenie form Ruby one that that clearly
he also can go to e6 attacking the the
bishop um but here Bishop c4 and just
bishop and seven is good yeah something
like this is a good position for wide
the e5 square is especially attractive
here for the night or bishop yeah why
does better here I can do this this may
be Queen to e5 it's very nice so the
move rookie one is probably the real
problem with this what I played I mean
it's not bad it gives white a strong
initiative but it is not as
as the rookie one option Bishop c4 is
what I played I'm a plate queen to d6
now I'm Korean c6 also was possible um
but white gets a very strong initiative
after 95 as well it doesn't feel very
logical a tool to just run into just
walk into this this 95 move yeah Queen
to be six and now rookie one is
interesting or something else and I
through P one in my analysis yeah just
yeah piling up a little bit here
building building pressure it's it's
difficult one point of this move is that
we should be six and now will be
answered by this line and wide wins in
exchange even though after 24 9 f8 and
there's this kind of situation um it's
not an easy win I mean for someone with
perfect technique may be but I feel that
this is still quite tricky to do but
even if you have perfect technique it's
not easy when the nights are probably
going to have pretty decent positions
and it's not easy for what to get a
person so just one line I mean it's very
difficult to come to clear conclusions
and analysis in such a complicated
position I understand that this look is
far more logical and can converse near
not not to step into the temple um yeah
my next move is probably not great I
mean I i just made a misjudgment on one
particular line him I played the move be
three in this position I'm trying to
play or threatening this should be tuned
and this has a problem though and I
think maybe this was the moment where he
could have gotten out of this is a
sticky situation the best movie is G
form it's a I mean I consider this but I
couldn't quite see how I'm playing after
Queen to f6 however if you look at this
a little bit with the computer it gives
Queen III and why it still has a very
strong initiative
yeah the night years since is pinned
this night is attacked and yeah it's
quite difficult for black Bishop you
success may be the best of all but yeah
this is still very dangerous after
Bishop g5 this is probably what I should
have done it's it's better than maybe
three move to be three idea has one big
problem let's go back and he can what he
played now is a leading black into yeah
into the difficulties that he ultimately
yeah couldn't solve Queen f6 is them
it's the best move and I saw that but
what I didn't see is Quincy to is Cle I
don't want to trade queens and aunty I
saw that twin takes a one it's not so
great yeah Queen takes a one Bishop b2
leads to a very nice position for white
yeah the point is that if he takes him I
have this move and it's quite funny and
the queen is running out of options here
tends to sacrifice on be to something
like this is over yeah I note that this
Bishop is pinning the F pawn now here
you can just like drop a couple of
things and then ultimately will be
checkmated yeah it's it's a nice line um
yeah okay he can take also here but
after after this the screen c3 idea is
very very strong yeah this I I actually
saw correctly but he has this move and
this is this is a very good defense the
idea is to put a knight on d4 why it
still has a quite substantial initiative
and it's not again not easy for black
but it seems that objectively speaking
he is alright yeah but should be to you
can put this on deform and mean
something like this it's just not very
convincing I can check and trade lots of
things and not really in danger of being
worse for example I can
you know don't see anything better I can
always just play something like this
where i would have enough compensation
for the pawn due to the better
development them this is bishop is still
at home andrew q1 is coming with the
temple this is always enough for pond
but white is not better if i want to get
more I maybe have to try something like
Bishop e3 which is still kind of
interesting the ideas to have to be true
and it can hang on b2 and ta let's say
after this this is a position that still
can be played White has quite nice
compensation here for the porn that is
it better for white or winning not
probably not and the other position was
I think objectively quite quite better
yeah he didn't play coming f6 so every
played the move Knight if form and this
is leads into into quite some trouble
and yeah it's very difficult it's really
difficult to judge the idea itself looks
very logical yeah Quincy tune and he
goes back to have 60 he has brought his
night over from c5 to f6 which should
help on to him to cover the King side
cover the king but it it just just
doesn't work it just doesn't work
because of whites a very strong
development yeah rook you want and we
went to be 6 Queen c6 again was a
possibility but it's very difficult to
play as you run into 95 the idea is this
but why it has a very strong game here
again and by playing the move Queen to
be to keeping the Queen's on the board
and this is actually very difficult to
blacken area we have to see that the
Queen on e form is not having many
squares in some cases it can get into
direct trouble and black has a hard time
to develop easily if you try something
like Bishop e6 for example then Bishop
g5
Bishop g5 is going to be quite quite
dangerous yeah note that the Queen has
no squares young much here f3 and the
queen is trapped funny line yeah it is
it is a very very dangerous position he
went to be 6 and ya know I don't have a
big choice here I need to push this
night away so g4 it's a gas
sharp-looking move but you have no
choice you have to now play initiative
moves all moves that come with tempo and
so on you cannot like play something
slow it's just not the position to to a
maneuver or whatever you just have to
play now move by move strong the most
aggressive moves if possible yay plate
96 on that's not not much much else and
here I missed an opportunity um and I
kind of saw the idea but I didn't see
how strong it actually was I I decided
to play Bishop e3 here which is not bad
yeah it's not a bad news but Bishop age
6 was stronger than the point was a
point is that now um yeah very
natural-looking move is rook e8 I think
on then after rupee eight white has a
very strong continuation and I saw the
idea but I couldn't quite make it work
rook takes these six this is a very very
funny idea the idea is that if black
takes with the pawn start with this then
cream to be too was very strong simply
threatening Queen f6 and then mating on
g7 the problem is that such as a ton of
ton of weird pins going on yeah if you
go screen the eighth for example Bishop
g5 king g7 and then something like this
black will not survive what is
threatening this for example
90 cannot get scheduled of this this pin
and something like h6 Bishop and form
you're also not going to survive the
threads group takes 26 this is a very
strong compensation but you can take
with sorry up to six you can take with
the Queen and I didn't quite see how
strong this is rook g1 okay Queen has to
move and here 95 is extremely strong so
I couldn't quite yeah I didn't quite see
her during the game the problem is that
moves like let's say you gave aid I mean
okay you can take it but Bishop f7 is
check a funny point as this is a check
check late it made very nice line so
after Bishop f7 white just flat-out wins
the rook there um yeah what is he
supposed to do bishop is six maybe yeah
and here again this is not I mean it
looks dangerous but I couldn't quite see
how strong it is here for example takes
takes Bishop takes this looks good but
is it the wind it's not so easy to
figure out if it wins g5 whatever is
strong stronger even is Queen 282
indisposition threatening Queen takes is
six and again after Queen B 6 days g5
and this is ultimately very very strong
I didn't I didn't see it during the game
how strong this is and also i mean i saw
that Bishop e3 is also not particularly
bad i anticipated that he would go Queen
c6 and I saw what happened in the game
on
the problems that he faces there and
that was quite happy with this and
didn't um try to make this Bishop age
six roop t6 work that hard because I
felt I also have something good here he
could have gone to 85 by the way which
would have been interesting here Bishop
age six is some also possible and okay
rookie a drupe d6 is very nice again
here but he can take on c4 and
disposition continue like that and it
would have been would have been a viable
option I think white is probably
somewhat better note that here he has to
place the night on some very unfortunate
square g8 yeah otherwise this Queen h8
mate it was Queen 85 but he went Queen
to c 6 which was also what I had
expected during the game yeah and now I
get 95 with the tempo and well he has to
move the Queen end yeah something
something like this is looking quite
terrible so he went to e form this this
much I expected and now Queen to see 3
yeah and the ideas now that there is the
idea of f3 trapping the Queen the black
Queen doesn't have many many squares and
the Queen on c3 is also nicely
positioned to look at the g7 square in
combination with bishop age six and the
interesting thing is that he went with
the snow and b6 and yeah now I started
to get quite excited because um here I
saw a combination that would win me the
game in a very nice way and I was just
hoping that he allows it and in fact he
did allow the combination which yeah it
was a very nice finish then after be 60
and a bishop age 6 right of course
attacking the rook and here he can try
to give the exchange back this is not a
bad choice objectively speaking he went
through p8 but something like there
should be six at least prevent some yeah
any checkmating things however after the
caption and something up sorry something
like this why does of course better I'm
the exchange up for a pawn but and this
is still something where black can try
to hope to defend its however it's not a
nice prospect I understand that you
don't want to do that and the thing is
he did here he overlooked my winning
combination and I mean yeah we would
seem rookie aid and yeah as I said now I
saw what what's possible and I was just
hoping he wouldn't deviate in some way
rupee one taking on the Queen it only
has to be seven square and now look 81
so I have got everything in play yeah
and now I saw that the most normal
natural-looking move Bishop e6 that this
would lose the game and he played it
pretty quickly at that time we had a
time situation I had roughly 25 to 30
minutes left and he had I think that 40
minutes left and he played this quite
quickly after one or two minutes and I
was quite excited here because I and you
that but should be six wouldn't work and
it is the horse normal-looking move um
yeah he played it and this is something
that you can use as a technical exercise
um yeah stop the video and try to figure
out why this does not work I'm going to
be silent for a moment and then continue
I just want to give you the chance to
pause also and I won't show it quite
quite immediately so you have now have
had enough time and what you should have
done by the way is Queen to c7 will see
afterwards
um why this is the only way to defend
after Bishop is sixth white can win
immediately and and very convincingly
with the very attractive move Knight to
d7 I was really a pleasure to play that
I really had to sit on my hands for a
moment because well I'd seen like four
moves ahead before that this would work
but I still rechecked the details and so
on you don't want to make this kind of
spectacular looking move and then see
that failing to some some defense that
you have overlooked yeah so what's the
point ninety seven obviously fails to
mate checkmate that doesn't work and I'm
threatening to play Knight f6 takes
Queen takes and then made on g7 so black
cannot just ignore the whole thing
Bishop takes is the only move that make
sense in this regard and now the point
that this is something that you
hopefully had seen up when you saw 97
there is the rook sacrifice now rook
takes a seven some play fighting the way
yeah clearing the way for the Queen to
take on f6 and then check made on g7
yeah now after the capture queen f6 it's
going to be made in a couple of moves
back on yes'm some lucky Desperados
Queen g7 mate is unavoidable so this
doesn't work and I'm just threatening to
take on f6 black only has one movie I
hope you saw the whole sequence because
it is really the whole sequence not just
the first move Queen c6 and now it's
interesting again if you want if you
didn't see the whole thing but just
maybe the idea or nothing at all can
still use this position to see how
should white now take on d 7 if you want
you can pause again and try to figure
out I can take with both rooks I can
take with this rope or with this rogue
but what is the best move
yeah the best capture is route 7 taking
on d 7 yeah this is actually not that
convincing after Luke takes root X rope
the eighth for example I don't have a
clear way of winning yeah I mean first
of all black is also threatening some
stuff but I don't have a clear way off
of advancing here here night h5 this is
just covering g7 very reliably but I can
take with this route and this is a lot
stronger the point is that this
threatens route 72 d 6 and this is
attacking the Queen and the night and
black only has rookie 6 as a sensible
looking move let's say to defend but
this doesn't work due to rupee a check
and now nothing that black can do if he
goes back I just go here get into
windows oh the capture check and now
still upside not there but here yeah
Queen takes f6 is the the nice little
pointer leading to the check late
getting to the mate yeah this is this
was some the the nice combination year
that was awesome I was able to play very
nice yeah what happened in the game
exactly this happen yeah 97 after longer
thought he took it rookie 7 and now
again Quincy six is the only move until
you took him quite a long time actually
expected him to resign at this point but
he played this move and yeah I didn't
quite get it no I'm just winning winning
material winning f6 or as he played in
the game he gave up his queen so I was a
queen up here for four look I used to
continue this I had time like 20 minutes
on the clock so it was a bit a bit
strange that he didn't just just resign
and that was are many ways to win why
does a clean up after all so here
threatening rookie aid okay Brooke a 8
you can just take stuff him check yeah
point it's not important and now you
just march the ape on home and we'll
promote your new queen so it was a very
nice victory against a strong
Grandmaster he had taken I think too
many risk there but trying to complicate
the game we want to go back there
whatever to this critical position oops
I'm sorry it was a bit much this
position where i saw that i have to
threat 97 this is also happening by the
way of black I mean we should be six we
saw in the game it loses 97 is the
threat here so if he plays I know it
probably doesn't make much sense anyhow
but something like this or so I still go
97 yeah so this is the threat and he has
to do something about the thread the
only move the absolute is the only move
that does not lose straight away is
Queen to c7 the ideas that now 97
doesn't work because in this line he has
Queenie 5 this is why Queen c7 is
essential to being able to here to here
and protect g7 so what happens after
Queen c7 and you have a very meek option
you can go Bishop f4 threatening
discoveries and the black Queen doesn't
have anything better than going back and
then you can make a draw however what I
wanted to do is and I didn't really want
to make it raw I mean it was very clear
that my initiative feels very strong
after Queen c7 and it's not so easy to
choose the to choose a move because they
are some attractive options one move
that actually two moves ahead on the
radar Bishop see one that is a very
interesting idea putting the bishop back
here so then ultimately after
some g5 you have mating ideas this is a
move that I liked a lot and is also
supported by stock visions being quite
attractive it gives wider +1 them this
is some difficult assessment in this
kind of position um but it shows that
it's probably giving white good chances
the other move that I've found very
attractive and I will and not question
what I would have played is route to
deform this has a couple of ideas the
main idea is to play that group f4 and
then have this option of taking here
like very crude a crook at 49 move ruge
f6 and made on g7 at the end this is
also very attractive and given as the
best move on by the engine after you let
it calculate for a while um black really
has a hard time to arrange his PCM for
example if you go some ambition is six
here Knight f3 and tending rook f4 is
already winning for white note that
after g5 night h5 there is also rook h4
so if you look at this for example this
is a huge idea in wide wins yeah Luke
the force is quite strong i mean i'm not
quite sure what I would have done it's
also like the idea of Bishop see one
it's very attractive-looking move the
best is probably be fired according to
the comp and after look at for ditching
upon but it's quite clear that only
white can be better here it's equal
material and something like this is
still going to be very dangerous however
it's what he had to play Queen c7 was
the only move otherwise this 97 tactic
is killing black so um let's look at one
or two key moments of this game I think
what you take from this is maybe for for
other games it's one particular
situation I think that
is very important like he am he took on
c3 and you shouldn't be afraid to give
up a pawn against the stronger player if
you feel like this is the right
continuation Quincy five is just is just
a very yeah it's psychologically also
very weak move yeah you should just play
this and you have enough compensation if
you see that you have the very strong
Bishop here that is always ready to put
to be put on the long diagonal or to h6
you have this tempie so why it has a
very strong compensation if you feel
like you get a compensation from the
pawn you should so being able to to
sacrifice that point even against them a
stronger player yet try to play in a
brave way against the stronger player
and the stronger player always wants you
to play passively and if you can avoid
this play actively it's always the
better recipe playing passive moves
against a stronger opponent is what what
he wants yeah and here in these kind of
situations i mean we saw that on both
sides made some mistakes or inaccurate
moves this is actually helping you if
you want to beat a stronger player
because yeah it gets it gets sharper and
it gets in many cases to a situation
where he can actually go wrong the
stronger player very rarely goes wrong
in a strategic judgment or an endgame
judgment or so but if it's about
dynamics quite often um yeah you'd
simply hit the right moves when you have
the initiative without even um yeah
clearly knowing that you play the right
moves just like it sometimes just flows
like here I mean I was always very
confident that I have enough for the
pawn but it got very concrete only here
when when I saw that okay the Queen has
very little squares and right here when
we come to this position I saw this this
winning idea with 97 which is I mean I
always thought I must have enough due to
my great development and only here it
was this concrete company
that that won this game in this nice
nice way yeah Quincy 7 was the best
offense but we see that even very strong
players can can fail if they have to yet
defend in this very accurate accurate
way it's not not easy at all to make
this kind of defensive moves and see all
the all the tricks yeah and this is a
very nice finish of the game Black has
no defense to that yeah I hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this game it was
one of my I think most attractive
combinations that I had against a
stronger player and it's very nice it's
also the highest rated player that I've
ever beaten so I am yeah I'm pretty
happy with the game I hope you enjoyed
to watch the video and as i said i'm
going to post a couple of more of those
um over the next couple of weeks I'm not
quite sure how many end in which kind of
rhythm like how often but I try to
present a couple because there were a
couple of good games or interesting
games at least them to show ok guys
thanks for watching